La extrema derecha está arrasando en
toda Europa,
países como Francia, Holanda o Austria
tienen partidos xenófobos con
posibilidades reales de llegar al
gobierno.
Sin embargo, España vive ajena a esta
tendencia y la pregunta es ¿por qué?
Hoy en VisualPolitik te lo vamos a contar
y lo vamos a hacer de la mano de Víctor
Fernández doctorando en Ciencia
Política en la Universidad de Estocolmo
y nuevo colaborador de este canal.
A raíz de las últimas elecciones en
Austria hace un mes
pudimos ver de nuevo en los titulares
cómo la extrema derecha está avanzando
Europa.
El candidato verde ganó al candidato
del FPÖ austriaco Hofer por apenas unos miles
de votos y gracias a que captó el voto de
todos los partidos que se habían
quedado a las puertas de la segunda ronda.
"La
extrema derecha europea celebra unánime
el triunfo del FPÖ en Austria".
¿Por qué está ascendiendo tanto la extrema derecha en
Europa? Podemos ver unas ciertas
similitudes comunes en todos los
partidos de extrema derecha alrededor de Europa. Si bien es cierto que no podemos comparar a
unos con otros por ejemplo Amanecer Dorado es imposible compararlo con por
ejemplo Perussuomalaiset en Finlandia o el propio FPÖ en Austria.
Sin embargo como he dicho hay unas ciertas similitudes comunes que podemos
analizar la primera es el nacionalismo
también hay un
cierto antiliberalismo y una tendencia a
estatalizar los medios de producción,
estatalizar la banca, estatalizar las energías, etc.
El 19 de septiembre puedes elegir entre
frenar la inmigración o frenar las
pensiones. Vota a los demócratas de
Suecia: seguridad y tradición.
También podemos ver un intento de
control cada vez más amplio sobre las
fronteras y sobre la inmigración y todos
estos partidos han ido creciendo por el miedo
la población que presentan personas de
otras culturas, que hay ciertos problemas
que los partidos tradicionales no han sabido
resolver o que no han sabido tratar, puesto
que llevarlos al debate público quizá
estaba mal visto.
"¿Y en España, qué pasa? ¿No
hay partidos de extrema derecha?"
Sí hay, pero es totalmente
irrelevante en el debate político.
Tenemos ahora mismo 3 falanges tenemos dos
plataformas per Catalunya tenemos una
"España en marcha" que es una coalición
de varias formaciones pero realmente
ninguna en ningún momento entra en
debate público consigue ningún tipo de
apoyo mediático ni es relevante ningún
sentido.
"Defendemos nuestro caudillo que sacrificó
su vida por la patria"
España como Portugal son dos casos especiales en
Europa, son los dos países donde digamos
que la extrema derecha menos ha cuajado y
quizá en el caso de España es por
su anclaje en el franquismo y su anclaje a las antiguas estructuras que sustentaron
el franquismo en su época.
"Eran basura contra los Reyes Católicos,
contra Franco, contra la Reconquista,
contra la Iglesia Católica".
Vemos cómo en el año 79 sí que un
diputado de extrema derecha, Blas Píñar,
en este caso consiguió un escaño por
Madrid en las cortes generales pero esto
no se volvió a repetir. Los mensajes que ha
trasmitido la extrema derecha en
españa se han quedado muy anticuados,
una extrema derecha que no ha renunciado en
ningún momento al franquismo, no ha renunciado en ningún
momento incluso partes que quedan sido
más identificadas con el fascismo, con el
nacionalsocialismo, tampoco han
renunciado a los crímenes fascistas o
los crímenes nacionalsocialistas
como puede ser el genocidio y digamos todos
juntos "arriba España", "arriba Cristo Rey", "arriba España".
Y es una derecha pues que
se mantiene muy reaccionaria en unas
posiciones que no atraen a la gran
masa de la población.
"Vencimos y venceremos, tenemos fé en Dios".
¿Pero realmente se ha modernizado la derecha
europea?
Los partidos de extrema derecha europeos sí que se ha
habido un reciclaje completo esos
partidos
sí que es verdad que algunos como
Amanecer Dorado o como el NPD en
Alemania que esta ahora mismo en proceso de
ilegalización nunca en ningún momento han
reformado su mensaje y esto le ha valido
desaprobación de todos los sectores de la sociedad y
de hecho solamente en Grecia han crecido
por la grave crisis económica en la que está
sumida el país que es la más
grave desde la segunda guerra mundial
que tienen allí. Sin embargo, en los demás países de Europa
este proceso ha sido ha sido apabullante
y considero que Europa ha cometido un
error en el pasado, debería haber
establecido relaciones de cooperación
de desarrollo económico con África
porque creo que es una de las maneras de
fijar a las poblaciones en su país de
origen. Todos los partidos de extrema
derecha en ningún momento apoyan en el
holocausto nazi de hecho condenan el
genocidio, condenan en el nazismo,
condenan el fascismo, condenan incluso
que se deporte de forma sistemática a
todos los inmigrantes es un discurso
completamente renovado y que pueda
atraer a gran parte de sociedad que
ahora mismo se siente desarraigada
por los partidos tradicionales.
"Eso es lo que repite la clase política, que lucha contra nosotros día a día"
¿Y cuáles son los motivos por los que no
surgen partidos de extrema derecha al
estilo europeo en España?
Bueno, pues hay varios tenemos el
catolicismo que aunque no lo creamos es
muy importante, tenemos la procedencia de
la inmigración, tenemos el propio
proceso centralizador de España de
de formación como nación, tenemos las
luchas por el poder y tenemos la ley
electoral. Son cinco factores muy muy
importantes para conocer por qué la
extrema derecha no ha triunfado en España.
"Número uno: el sistema electoral"
El primer factor en este caso sería la ley electoral. En las elecciones de 1979
Blas Piñar consiguió un diputado pero
consiguió 300.000 votos. Esta extrema derecha tardofranquista quizás con una
ley electoral más proporcional hubiese
obtenido más escaños.
Sin embargo entre este problema con
la ley electoral y luego el golpe de
estado fracasado del año 81 hicieron
que la población se sintiera
completamente desraizada y completamente
en contra de una extrema derecha que
podía volver, que nos podría
hacer volver a los tiempos de Franco.
Numero 2: la inmigración.
La inmigración
es muy importante en España puesto que
en España, a diferencia de los otros
países de Europa, tiene una inmigración
proveniente de hispanoamérica con una
misma lengua con una misma lengua, una misma cultura con
una misma religión y esto es muy
importante puesto que incluso los
sectores más reaccionarios de nuestra
sociedad están a favor de este tipo de
inmigración. Puesto que al ser más
religiosos  hace que muchos crean que
puede ser la salvación digamos del
catolicismo la vuelta de los valores
tradicionales a la España actual.
Número 3: el
catolicismo.
Y hablando de catolicismo para la mayoría los países de Europa
la unión entre religión y extrema derecha
actualmente es muy escasa.
"Creo que prohibir el aborto no es un
buen método" Sin embargo en España
se ha dado de siempre por la dictadura de
Franco. En ese aspecto en la España de
la transición sí que hubo una alianza
de los partidos digamos más de
extrema derecha europea y los partidos
tardofranquistas o partidos católicos
propiamente dicho. Camaradas con la España en
marcha, con la falange con alianza
nacional, con democracia nacional, con la unión patriota español, con el movimiento
católico español.
Sin embargo actualmente esto es imposible
dado que un partido de extrema
derecha europea aunque no esté
reciclado como éstos nunca
va a aceptar ningún tipo de inmigración, sin
embargo un partido católico sí que te
va a aceptar una inmigración
culturalmente igual como por ejemplo
puede ser la hispanoamericana como os hemos
hablado antes. Por tanto, este tipo de
división hace que sea imposible una
conjunción entre ambos tipos de partido
al tener el fondo una ideología
bastante diferente
"Número cuatro: las divisiones internas"
Es importante hablar de que en España
también la extrema derecha siempre ha
estado muy atomizada ahora mismo existen
tres tipos de falange diferentes unas
enfrentadas con otras, dos tipos de
plataforma per catalunya y
todo estos procesos son tan interesantes
como caóticos para los propios partidos
porque son unas luchas de poder por
partidos minúsculos tremendas, algo que
en otros partidos y en otros países no existe.
En Francia, en Alemania, en Hungría tenemos
partidos fuertes que tendrán su lucha de
poder pero ningún momento hacen dividir
al partido.
"No vengáis a Francia de verdad, si no os va
a gustar está todavía lloviendo hace
una humedad malísima, que eso para el
pelo africano es fatal ya lo sabéis
vosotros"
Un asunto al que se ha prestado
poca atención en la prensa española y
en general incluso en la europea
es en los postulados económicos de estos
partidos.
En España los postulados económicos antiliberales han sido adoptados por los
partidos de extrema izquierda pero en ningún
momento han sido adoptados por la extrema derecha,
cosa que en Finlandia, en Suecia, en
Francia sí que se han usado
muchísimos. El lema principal de Marie
Le pen, uno de los lemas principales, es
acabemos con los recortes, acabemos
con el neoliberalismo salgamos del euro.
"La ultraderecha es la que está a la
derecha de la derecha, la que considera
que hay que tener todavía más ultra
liberalismo casi en el límite de la ley
de la selva".
En filandia el partido verde
los verdaderos finlandeses está bajando
las encuestas no porque de repente la
población finlandesa esté a favor de
los refugiados sino porque había
defendido una salida del euro, ha sido
un partido así ha defendido un fin de
los recortes y al final acabó pactando
con un partido liberal y con un partido
de centro agraria que lo que han hecho
ha sido seguir con esos recortes y han
tenido que tragar.
"El apoyo al partido de
los finlandeses cae por debajo del 10%"
¿Y vosotros qué creéis, existen más
factores que impida la entrada de
partidos políticos de extrema derecha
en el parlamento?
¿Creéis que próximamente a medio plazo
podría desaparecer algún partido nuevo
de extrema derecha?
Esperamos vuestros comentarios para abrir
debate y bueno muchas gracias y hasta la
próxima